Звичайний робочий день, а в цьому районі Потсдама ніби всі вимерли.
7,5 тисяч місцевих жителів змушені були залишити свої оселі
та виїхати з зони оточення до 8-ої ранку.
Тих, хто не може ходити, вивозить "швидка".
А співробітники служби громадського порядку
обходять під'їзд за під'їздом, квартиру за квартирою,
щоб перевірити, чи всі виконали розпорядження місцевої влади.
Штраф за перебування у зоні евакуації - 1000 євро.
За кілометр звідси повним ходом триває підготовка
до контрольованого вибуху. Тут будують пліт з пресованої соломи,
який має скоротити радіус розльоту осколків від детонації
250-кілограмової американської бомби. 75 років вона пролежала
на дні цього озера й іншим способом її не знешкодити.
З моменту возз'єднання Німеччини в одному лише Потсдамі
було знешкоджено понад 200 бомб. Порядок дій відпрацьований
настільки, що міська адміністрація навіть влаштовує
престур для журналістів до місця події
Складність полягає в тому, що ми маємо справу з бомбою,
яка лежить під водою. А це значить, що ми не можемо
її ретельно вивчити. Тобто мені потрібно покладатися на роботу
військових дайверів. Але я впевнений, що і сьогодні
все пройде без проблем.
Загалом в операції задіяні 450 осіб. У мерії Потсдама працює
кризовий штаб. Там кажуть, що подібні розмінування з евакуацією -
звична справа.
Якщо ми дізнаємося, що хтось не вийшов з квартири
або помічаємо, що хтось ще перебуває всередині, тоді, звичайно,
вживаються заходи. Ми і двері можемо виламати, якщо що.
Якщо люди добровільно не виходять. Так-так, тому що існує
реальна небезпека і, відповідно, всі жителі мають вийти з зони оточення.
Через кілька годин бомба буде успішно ліквідована і жителі
зможуть повернутися додому. До наступного знешкодження.
А у військово-історичному музеї Бундесверу на колишньому
військовому аеродромі Ґатов, що на околиці Берліна, бомбам
часів Другої світової війни присвячена ціла експозиція.
Масштаби тут оцінюють дуже приблизно: на "третій рейх"
було скинуто близько 2 мільйонів тонн бомб, і частка тих, що
не вибухнули, може становити від 5% до 20%.
У землі, як і раніше, стільки всього лежить, що сапери кажуть:
безробіття нам поки точно не загрожує.
Звучить жахливо, але так воно і є.
Найбільше бомб знаходять у двох регіонах Німеччини: Рурській області
і Берліні та його околицях. Причому мова йде не тільки про важкі
авіабомби, а й про менші боєприпаси.
Для гостей виставки організатори створили вікторину:
два десятки залізяк у пісочниці. Половина з них вибухонебезпечна,
а решта - просто металобрухт.
Ми помічаємо, наскільки здивовані бувають наші відвідувачі й наскільки
часто вони помиляються у визначенні того, бомба перед ними
чи ні. І головне, чого ми хочемо досягти за допомоги цієї виставки, -
це зайвий раз звернути увагу відвідувачів, наскільки небезпечним
може бути те, що можна знайти на прогулянці в лісі або копаючи город,
і що в таких випадках треба завжди телефонувати в поліцію.
У Берліні, як і в Потсдамі, триває бурхливе будівництво.
За допомогою матеріалів аерозйомок, зроблених союзниками
під час війни, фахівці шукають місця, де можуть лежати бомби,
які не вибухнули. Внаслідок такого цілеспрямованого пошуку, до речі,
і була виявлена бомба на дні озера у Потсдамі,
для нейтралізації якої знадобилося стільки соломи.